here we are again with the indomitron
6000. our state-of-the-art simulation
computer that helps us create hyper
accurate simulations of some of the
world's most bizarre scenarios whether
it's scp-096 versus siren head able vs
chainsaw man or now perhaps our most
ridiculous matchup yet
scp-035 the Diabolical possessive mask
versus The Mask the popular Jim Carrey
character based on the hyper-violent
comic book of the same name so what the
heck are we waiting for let's crank up
the machine and see what the results are
somebody stop me okay so what have we
got on intake today researcher were best
a tone of boredom hanging off his every
word uh possible anomalous entity his
compatriot Dr mackney replied sipping
his coffee sounding equally as
unenthused Caucasian male early 30s a
team of our agents picked him up in the
foundation doctor checked his notes some
place called Edge City real appealing
tourist spot he added sarcastically now
what's so anomalous about him warp
questioned his eyes lazily scanned over
a file mackney had handed him says here
he's just an ordinary bank teller
there's one prior arrest on his record
but the charges were dropped later on
and the sky's a nobody apparently he was
in possession of an anomalous artifact
came the doctor's reply he looked
through the one-way glass into the
interrogation room sat at the table
wearing a matching pair of hideous
pajamas was a wiry brown-haired man what
was it researcher worb asked not
bothering to check the file a mask
apparently mackney replied this thing
can form a symbiotic connection with
whoever wears it this guy's had it for a
while it causes him to undergo a
dramatic intensification of his
personality when he puts it on as well
as granting him some unusual abilities
hold on aren't you just describing as
cp035 worb said looking confused nope
the doctor responded by handing him a
clear evidence bag and it was a single
wooden mask a dull darkish green tint to
the object it looked to be almost Viking
in its design with three holes on its
surface one for the mouth and two for
the eyes it was hard to deny it was
completely different from the white
porcelain of
scp-035 what's this guy's name again
website looking at the scruffy pajama
clad man waiting for them ipkiss his
colleague replied Stanley ipkus
meanwhile locked up tight in a
hermetically sealed glass case was
another anomalous mask
scp-035 was kept under lock and key by
the foundation guarded constantly by a
pair of armed security officers one of
them officer regert had noticed
something strange about the infamous
possessive mass today or it's Stranger
than usual anyway
scp-035 was known to compel people to
wear it if they were close enough often
through subtle psychic Whispers but
today it seemed Restless almost agitated
like it found something nearby to be
intensely annoying I already told you
everything I know Stanley ibka signed
exhaustedly he'd been dragged out of bed
at the crack of dawn by strange agents
and was now being interrogated about
what he knew of the wooden mask he'd
come across floating in the river one
fateful night I don't know where it came
from I swear I didn't even realize I
still had it we threw it back in the
river but my dog must have swung out and
fetched it Stanley explained you have no
idea what this thing is not even from
any first-hand experience Mr ebkiss Dr
mackney asked holding the mask up look I
did take it to a psychologist who told
me it might be Scandinavian a
representation of some Norse night God
the Loki I think he answered we're not
interested in this mask as a historical
art piece researcher were retorted tell
us what happens when you put it on
Stanley paused for a moment clearly
aware he was in real trouble but nervous
about coughing up the details to his
Shady captors with a sigh he decided it
was best to confess us
I don't know how it works but whenever
you put it on it's like it brings your
deepest desires to life I wear that mask
I can do anything be anything he
described remembering a key detail but
it only works at night Dr mackney and
researcher werev exchanged looks
uncertain if ipkiss was just a lunatic
or if there was truth to what he was
telling them assemble a security team
McNeese side will arrange a safe
environment for you tonight Mr utkus
elsewhere in the facility regert and his
fellow security officer Duggan was
watching over scp-035 with growing
concern what do you reckon has this
thing so agitated Dugan wondered aloud
who knows regert side I've already
reported it to command told them zero
three fives in a mood they said to
proceed as normal suddenly as the words
left his mouth officer regert felt
strange it was like he had been hooked
by an overwhelming urge to put the
possessive mask on he barely noticed he
had reached to unlock the door sealing
the area where scp-035 was contained in
its case and as he stepped through
officer Dugan's pleas for him to stop
barely registered the other officer
tried in vain to pull regard back as he
walked towards the possessive mask only
to feel his co-worker grip his shirt and
swing him face first over and over again
into the glass case containing the
anomalous object his body going
completely limp after being used to
break the glass rigor dropped Dugan to
the floor too lost in his trance-like
state to realize he'd just killed a
fellow Foundation security officer he
was too focused on scp-035 as he lifted
it up and placed it over his face
meanwhile Stanley idkis had been brought
to a testing area a team of security
officers standing around him the fact
that they were all armed did little to
ease Stanley's nerves Dr mackney
strolled up to him pulling the green
wooden mask out of the airtight bag it
had been sealed in and handed it to
Stanley now funny business Mr ipkiss the
doctor warmed I really can't promise
that
Stanley replied he looked at the mask in
his hands noticed a green Shimmer over
the reverse side of it as much as he had
gladly given it up part of him had
missed wearing it he could already hear
the low rumbling of thunder outside as
he lifted it towards his face feeling it
almost leap out of his hands and latch
itself onto him the green mask eagerly
became attached to Stanley the surface
of it spreading out where it covered his
face and wrap around his entire head
around him the guards cautiously stepped
back as they watched Stanley convulse
and writhe around the place
uncontrollably like a man possessed both
researcher word and Dr mackney looked at
each other in wordless disbelief before
turning back to the scene unfolding
Before Their Eyes the booming noise of
thunder and cracks of lightning rang out
despite this all taking place indoors as
Stanley ifkiss vanished in the center of
a miniature tornado that spun wildly
around the testing area before slowing
to a halt in its place stood a maniacal
wide-eyed figure dressed in a garish
yellow zoot suit and wearing an enormous
tooth grin on his bright green face how
do fellas the mass bombastically hooted
at the guards having been trained to
deal with absurd anomalies of Plenty the
security Team all defensively raised
their weapons out of a mix of instinct
and confusion fish rough ground The
green-faced Lunatic stated to nobody it
looked like he had turned aside as if
addressing some invisible audience
outstretching both arms and one leg The
Mask instantly zipped off hurling around
the room in a whirlwind of absurdity in
the style of an old Tech Savory cartoon
the spinning cackling combination of
Stanley ipkiss and the Magical mask
weaved in between the foundation guards
all of whom tried in vain to restrain
him until he disappeared out of the door
after after him Dr mackney yelled with
urgency in his voice the guards all
turned to run after the mask only for
each one of them to trip over and land
face first on the floor of the testing
area as if something had tied them all
up by their ankles it was only after the
security officers all struggled back up
to their feet that they noticed their
pants had been yanked down leaving the
foundation's finest somewhat embarrassed
to say the least outside the testing
area Stanley or rather the mask had
already closed the door behind him out
of nowhere he produced a series of
wooden planks and began hammering them
into the door frame boarding it up
before speedily adding chains and
padlocks to the mix sighing and in an
over-exaggerated manner wiping the sweat
from his brow he turned around only to
be met with the sight of even more SCP
Foundation guards lying in weight their
guns all trained on him the mass gave a
scream of pure Terror that briefly sent
his skull popping out of his head and
his eyes shooting out of his skull
before everything zipped right back into
its origin National Place his eyes
started to round at the faces of the
foundation's security wondering how he
was going to get out of this one oh gee
this all seems familiar he said either
to himself or with his audience well if
it ain't broken hit it in the blink of
an eye the mask's bright yellow outfit
had transformed replaced by a silk blue
Rumba shirt with ruffled sleeves white
pants and a wide brim black hat as they
watched him stood at the ready a few of
the cards noticed the sound of music not
one of them could tell where it was
coming from nor could they help starting
to tap their feet or Bob their heads to
the rhythm of the Cuban Pete Rumba the
entire security team quickly erupted
into a full-blown dance number that
anyone who saw it couldn't resist
joining all led by The Mask wildly
waving Maracas in the air and singing
elsewhere in the facility officer regert
was beginning to melt he still had
scp-035 covering his face the frown of
the possessive Mass conveying the
entity's sheer discontent the black ooze
secreting from its porcelain surface had
the unfortunate effect of corroding and
melting down anyone that wore it
dissolving them entirely after a short
period of time determined scp-035 pushed
on plotting its host towards a storage
room if it remembered correctly the SCP
Foundation had stored a number of
temporary hosts for it mannequins that
while not human had enough of a humanoid
shape for the possessive mask to use of
course after all of its attempts to
escape the foundation had rescinded its
privilege to be granted new hosts not
that it could stop it from taking them
by force using the last of Officer
regert's dwindling strength
scp-035 barched its way into the
storeroom sure enough waiting there for
it was a row of discarded mannequins
lifting regert's hands before they had
fully melted away the possessive mask
used him to place itself on a new body
elsewhere not too far away in the
foundation facility a conga line of
security officers and research personnel
now was parading through the corridors
all happily dancing and jiving to the
music despite still no one being able to
figure out where it was coming from
dashing away from his spot at the front
of the line the mask zipped around a
corner his clothes having changed back
to his signature brightly colored Zoot
Suit never say no to a party he
exclaimed after having danced his way to
Freedom the sound of something shuffling
closer quickly caught the mask's
attention he turned around to find
himself standing green face to porcelain
face with scp-035 you the masked
mannequin raised a hollow arm pointing a
finger from its host at Stanley you bear
the god of mischiefs carving I could
sense its presence since you arrived
still in my luck nobody likes a copycat
Villa The Mask replied although
intimidation is the sincerest form of
flattery and that's how Jim Carrey's
career started
he added exploding with rash's laughter
cease you're prattling a CP 035 hist
with spite say perhaps we're related The
Mask ignored it oh we could be long lost
family you know I always wanted kids of
my own Son of the Mask has a nice ring
to it right he paused once again turning
away to his unseen audience on second
that
maybe not the scp-035 controlled
mannequin left forward gripping the
mask's arm causing him to scream and
shock at the advanced his eyes bulged
out of their sockets zooming in on the
corrosive black secretions oozing from
scp-035 the mannequin's other hand
started reaching upwards gripping his
oversized green head as if it were
trying to lift the mask right off of
Stanley's face zooming away again he
sped down the nearest Corridor his arms
stretching behind him still clamped in
scp-035's grip coming to a screeching
halt with the comical sound of car
breaks the mask wobbled his outstretched
arm a ripple traveled all the way along
the elongated limb as if it was made of
elastic his wrists still being held by
the mannequin sporting the possessive
mask the force of the flailing rubbery
arm was so great that it flung scp-035's
host body around sending it head first
into the ceiling then plummeting back
down to the ground it's grip loosened
allowing the mass to reel back its
stretchy arm although it didn't return
to normal length right away his own hand
pinged back and hit him in the face only
to start urgently trying to communicate
of its own accord what's that boy The
Mask said to his hand as it started
performing a series of signals little
Timmy stuck down a well you'd like a
Friday night off there's a two-bit jump
wearing another mask walking men to
sling down the hall towards us the hand
suddenly turned the mask said to look in
the right direction sure enough
scp-035 was using the mannequin to walk
down the hall towards him his elongated
arm quickly returned to its normal size
as the green face lunatic took a quick
draw stance facing his oncoming
adversary now you have to ask yourself
one question he sneered doing a fairly
convincing impression of a green Clint
Eastwood do I feel lucky with a sweep of
his hand The Mask had drawn an enormous
weapon the thing was a gigantic mass of
different artillery clicking and
whirring there were barrels on top of
barrels rockets and other explosives
locked into place do I feel lucky the
mass continued well do you punk
scp-035 did nothing to slow its advance
so the mask pulled the trigger every one
of his weapons various components spat
out a tiny flag with the word bang
written on it ah performance issue he
said doing his aside once again not that
I'm overcompensating for anything
clearly growing agitated piloting its
host
scp-035 started charging towards the
mask immediately he spun around becoming
a tornado of hyperactivity and whooping
noises as he sped down the adjacent
Corridor the possessive mask staggered
after him the use leaking from the
porcelain anomaly was Dripping onto the
mannequin wearing it causing the plastic
to be melted away exposing the flimsy
metal skeleton beneath it knew it had to
merge with a new host find something
else to corrupt scp-035 chased after the
cartoonish Troublemaker knowing that if
it could catch him he'd be able to
survive merging with it his body while
wearing the other mask barely obeyed the
laws of physics making him invulnerable
to damage and possibly even the
corrosive substance oozing from the
possessive mask as if those weren't
enough reasons his powers seemed
virtually Limitless combined with the
green-headed lunatic
scp-035 could do anything reaching a
stop at the end of another Corridor The
Mask spun around wearing a comically
undersized baseball uniform he reached
into his pocket and produced an
oversized baseball bat then proceeded to
start hurling baseballs into the air and
swatting them as hard as he could as the
mask increased the speed of his swings a
volley of hard-corked baseballs were
fired down the corridor like a barrage
of bullets ricocheting off the walls and
hitting the oncoming
scp-035 each one struck its Target
reeling the mannequin but doing little
much else to stop it getting closer and
closer until With An Almighty swing The
Mask brought his back crashing into
scp-06 5 with enough Force to send the
possessive mask and its hosts careening
down the corridor it sailed through the
air bursting through a wall then flew
into a research lab tearing a huge hole
in the next wall as it kept going
finally it came crashing out of the last
wall the outer wall of the facility and
dropped multiple stories to the ground
outside changing costumes back to his
classic suit and dashing after scp-035
the mask passed through all the holes
his adversary had left in the multiple
walls it had crashed into he screeched
to a halt again and paused after getting
through the outer wall only to realize
after a moment that he was hovering in
mid-air not standing on anything
reaching into his suit pocket The Mask
pulled out a sign on a stick with a
single word written on it yikes he
plummeted down to ground level Landing
with such an immense crash that his body
cracked into the asphalt below it left a
perfect outline of him imprinted in the
ground causing the mass to go completely
pancake flat head to toe suddenly before
he could peel himself up off the ground
and go back to being three-dimensional
scp-035 staggered to its host's feet and
pinned The Mask down finally it growled
I've caught you I've won your power is
mine once I've combined with you I will
be able to ravage this world I'm going
to fuse to your face then I'll start
with decimating those wretches that
imprison me the foundation will fall and
then so will the rest of their precious
World forcefully the mannequin's hand
wrenched the mask off the ground but as
scp-035 turned to look at what it had
hoped to be its next host well let's
just say the tragedy frown carved into
its porcelain face had never been more
appropriate it wasn't holding the mask
it was holding a life-size cardboard
cutout of a photo of the Mask grinning
out from one side enraged the possessive
Mass tore the decoy in half with its
mannequin's hands Hey Pachuco said a
cartoonish voice from right behind it
did you miss me the mask had reappeared
for real this time grinning with his
huge teeth clearly getting a kick out of
having someone to torment
scp-035 on the other hand had been
getting increasingly irritated by all
the wacky cartoon Antics with all the
aggression it could Channel through its
mannequin host it gripped The Mask by
the throat his eyes bulging out of his
head again
the possessive mask yelled having
finally run out of patience you know
what I won't merge with you I should
just kill you and put an end to your
buffoonery let me take this thing off
you first though its mannequin fingers
started to hook into the mask's seam at
the back of his bald green head wait
wait The Mask bag putting up both his
hands and surrender at least give me a
final request huh Master mask before the
possessive mask could respond the mask
had swept it off its dissolving
mannequin feat he started to spin it
around in a wild over-the-top dance
number bopping and Swinging to a tune
that seemed to be coming from nowhere
the longer it went on for the more and
more of scp-035's host's body started to
dissolve away until the mannequin
finally wasted away all that was left
was a bubbling pile of black goo on the
ground with the possessive mask laying
in the middle The Mask chuckled noticing
the fumes trailing upwards into the air
as the corrosive substance melted away
the last of
scp-035's host talk about smoking now go
and check out what if scp-343 wore
scp-035 and the whole story what if
scp-096 wore scp-035 for more Adventures
from the evil scp-035